pop
[Musique]
non
à
là
[Musique]
oui
différé à la poche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien qu'ils entrent je vous présente le
commandant janvier monsieur hubert
gagner je gagnais représente le
ministère de la défense alors janvier
ses vedettes
chacun de ces esprits en particulier cet
avion
l'ensemble c'est à dynamiter parfait
sont pas là pour gonfler des ballons
rouges mais vont réussir une mission
dont le moins qu'on puisse dire est
qu'elles sortent de l'ordinaire
ils savent tout faire ils ont tous fait
des conneries comprise bien entendu fou
bref faso il totalise quand même 120
citation 3 légion d'honneur 10 médailles
militaires
j'espère que vous êtes satisfait et où
les avez vous mis vos grands faux là ils
attendent à côté
ces légionnaires tous sous-officiers
chevronnés ont été rassemblés afin de
participer à une opération de commando
particulièrement délicate et dangereuse
tous parachutistes tous grands
combattants des guerres modernes
ils sont en outre brevetée dans diverses
spécialités
certains d'entre eux possèdent également
des dons d'imagination et
d'improvisation qui leur ont permis de
se sortir victorieusement des situations
les plus imprévus les plus exceptionnels
c'est le passé de chacun de ces hommes
que nous avons voulu évoquer avant qu'il
ne s'embarque pour ce commando qui va
les mener vers leur destin sergent-chef
leur ait dit
[Musique]
village d'à quoi ta dente au pied du
monte à miata devant le col et le
village de radicaux fanny 18 juin 1944
[Musique]
depuis trois jours les alliés sont
bloqués devant une chaîne montagneuse le
1er bataillon de la 13e demi brigade de
légion étrangère s'est implantée dans le
village d'à quoi ta dente situées au
pied d'un python le monde d aminata qui
verrouille la porte de la toscane
conscient de l'importance stratégique de
cette forteresse naturelle les allemands
ont installé huit pièces d'artillerie
lourde
dans des grottes inexpugnable
[Applaudissements]
ils comptent endiguer le raz-de-marée
alliés pour un temps qui leur
permettrait d'organiser leur retraite et
la réalisation beaucoup plus au nord
d'une nouvelle ligne de défense
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non même pas
comment tard
accusant m
de nouveau voir leurs consignes
commandante important importante
important to me semblent importantes
jenny reprenne dit vas-y via ce qui veut
dire en clair que le 15 juin 44 à 5h30
heure les alliés déclencheront une
attaque simultanée les américains à
gauche les canadiens à droite et le
premier régiment de la 3e brigade à la
légion attaquera au centre pour nous
seul massacre général américain qui
vient de voir ses autrement il dit la
légion créera une diversion alors on
donne au quartier libre zone pour ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
il
[Musique]
non
bonne nuit
[Musique]
m
mais
on va d'abord sous la passerelle à la
confidence à temps et mieux encore il
est qu à voter sur le tente orange est
hélas trop peu joué avant de parfaire la
vita basta enfin la poutine a commandé à
l'entrée les vannes ouest ont condamné
la troupe ar mathivet armati la gloire
et cosy et doha par totti ces italiens
si johnny tendu par la déconne et
commandante nomika puisque ni mandora
l'inserm cause avoir aidé à louis à
dessau to buy arcade ni à cabidos akkad
mcavoy de le commandant kouakou ce
domaine
ouest
quoi cela va nous fait chier supériorité
desk nouvelle trouvaille de disques
place ou la soul david mccomas fatah pas
salir la soucoupe passage de sa grille
et il est du pays il connaît le chemin
il l'a fait deux fois il accompagnait
son père travaillait à la construction
des locaux il pourrait le camp des échos
d'abord demandé à ses parents non
justement
il dit que ce sont les allemands qui les
ont tués à évin cuisse là-haut à
l'accord nahd d'accord vas-y
si le monde travaille pour les allemands
au risque que la ville indique toute
façon c'est bien là qu'il soit 7 me sur
la colline où deux mains à l'eau si vous
permettez mon capitaine julien quand
même un oeil sur le golf et mines cela
c'est sûr tu te rappelles
céline
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça t'a oublié nous le dira
ap
-la prime abord attaqué nos fans c'est
la première fois qu'ils font ça
de toute façon on n'a plus le choix
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu en penses génie il est
bien beau lieu de 20 secondes
[Musique]
colonel la soupe est arrivé
je tiens versa
oui
asuka comme ça
[Musique]
oh
non
à l'époque j'étais à rome
[Musique]
et
bon
[Musique]
ouais
ah ah
[Musique]
à
non
en avant
[Musique]
alors johnny comment ça va tiens on
n'est pas riche
non c'est pour ça qu'il veut s'il a fait
tout ça c'était pour qu'on s'occupe de
sa soeur pour être tranquille son sujet
rien que ça et lui alors ajustements
ce qu'il veut c'est rester avec nous
tout va bien
vidic mais anodin et maicon
ciao
toi
les gens
[Musique]
à
ap rabais
[Musique]
à l'étranger
ces légionnaires tous sous-officiers
chevronnés ont été rassemblés afin de
participer à une opération de commando
particulièrement délicate et dangereuse
tous parachutistes tous grands
combattants des guerres modernes qui
sont en outre brevetée dans diverses
spécialités
certains d'entre eux possèdent également
des dons d'imagination et
d'improvisation qui leur ont permis de
se sortir victorieusement des situations
les plus imprévus les plus exceptionnels
c'est le passé de chacun de ces hommes
que nous avons voulu évoquer avant qu'il
ne s'embarque pour ce commando qui va
les mener vers leur destin adjudant
castor
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le tandem
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le troisième reich après d'ultimes
sursaut vient enfin de s'effondrer dans
un petit village d'allemagne proche de
la frontière suisse légionnaires et
jiyai ont improvisé un bal pour fêter
leur victoire
[Musique]
oui
où
qui
c
[Musique]
alors ça marche et rien auquel rentrer
avec sa soeur anne-sophie da patins
samedi si les ricains me raccompagne
rock fait moi c'était mais ça garde sera
complètement c'hlas pour un homélie sur
c'est un pierre on sort avec la première
c'est la deuxième qui te fais la gueule
quand tu sors avec l'autre et casse le
coup
[Musique]
il est normal en jeep colère bien
inventer la du site
demain
[Musique]
demain à 9,6 label'vie les grossesses de
mme à nous aussi on aura une type
[Musique]
à droite
à gauche
m
ce recul
allez je te dis que ça sent un peu la
maintenant tu peux braque allemand
merde
[Musique]
la faute à pas voulu du chevrolet du
doigt jean et du poids est ce que tu as
dans la tête
or angie pour ce terrible geste héroïque
pour sortir les gonzesses l'a pas
compris c'est pas les cons c'est ce qui
manque c'est l'egypte n'a pas ou alors
rien général de dans des salles sa
petitesse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
olivier aux fesses mais prudent 1 40 m
qui va nous arriver des bricoles
quand il y au fesses
[Musique]
et là on va les suivre jusqu'à berlin
ces [ __ ]
[Musique]
vous
rien vu rien pigé s'emploie d'appareils
photo une abbaye en ruine dans les
environs c'est là qu'ils vont de
touristes ouais des touristes à la
victoire
chapeau
bon qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
programme à pays ne doit plus être loin
c'est ça et pendant qu'ils prennent
leurs photos il prévient qu'il voyait en
photo nous n'aurons pas de la tipp les
mains des fans n'est pas tombé sur la
tête mon nom a les nerfs des voix
un master piste demain aux white le club
nordiste of oak et comment le buzz
[Musique]
des dizaines de fans de strikes et mme
johnston blue panorama note de 6 pb à 6
ingrid sobhraj sardane folle semaine du
boom town of greece spain in de suisse
devra d'ici 10 ans valentino était
maintenue
[Musique]
comme occidentaux
marchena sport ne l'a pas de maarten
nichée notorious big mac doom le maire
de challans boss souvent la sones 7e sp
à la justice libanaise merde non mais
t'as vu
[Musique]
je
et il n'y a pas d'homme avec eux dans
les ruines de l'abbaye g / sur mon
capitaine rien que des gosses et les
armes des armes individuelles mais je
n'ai pas vu de fusils mitrailleurs
ben c'est encore heureux et tu dis
qu'ils sont une quinzaine pas beaucoup
plus en tout cas
ouais c'est sûrement cette bande dite
les lyonnais n'ont recruté dans la
région et que les américains nous
avaient signalé leur young and by depuis
sa fameuse campagne de russie
il plaira racler les fonds de tiroir il
a mobilisé fanatisés tous les gamins
valide même les mômes de 13 ans et ceux
là sont les enfants du pays
et ça ne va pas nous faciliter les
choses merci les gars la star y avoir
ici
oui mon capitaine tu n'as rien oublié un
détail quelque chose non je ne pense pas
mon capitaine
vraiment il me semble que tu as oublié
de me dire ce que vous faisiez dans les
ruines toi et ton copain un mimizan et
moir vous intéresser à l'architecturé
cistercienne au nom du fils que vous
visitiez la région peut-être oui c'est
ça m'occupe du tourisme
la guerre est finie alors on pensait
enfin je croyais qu'en suivant la jeep
suffisamment longtemps
elle vous tomberez tout rôti dans les
bras c'est ça non et vous qui étiez
l'occasion de la volée de l'emprunter
mon capitaine me présenter c'est le
pèlerin le rapport pourrait disposer les
chefs de section à moi
la première et la troisième section
s'installeront autour des ruines aux
ordres du lieutenant laroche mission
premièrement interdire les itinéraires
sans être vu deuxièmement ne tirer que
sur mon ordre voir sans être vu ça vous
rappellera cherchell c'est si grave que
ça mon capitaine ça pour aller
mon capitaine je le contact avec les
américains mais aspect mon général
sega maintien de vos hommes en général
les ravines semble ok j'ai des trucs
tout autour mais je ne peux pas donner
l'assaut j'ai compris comme on dit à la
légion démerdez vous mais de voir mon
général
[Musique]
c'est pas malheureux c'est nous qui
avons tout fait et on nous laisse
derrière elle a écrasé après ta connerie
d'avoir été lire au vieux qu'on voulait
piquer la dgi on s'est fait canarder si
on n'est pas là pour leur expliquer
parce que toi tu sais ce qu'il faut
faire sur paca échanger les amerloques
content du chocolat tokyo dame airlock
onkyo de chocolat les a pas vus ces
morpions sont plus dangereux qu'une
compagnie de ss3 le capturer par les
grandes chaînes des gretchen
qu'est-ce qu'il ya encore avec les
grandes chaînes ou annuler ces camions
sa veuve là que ça repart alors oui les
ce camion qu'est ce que c'est que cette
nouvelle connerie
[Applaudissements]
vous contrôlez les accès l'affirmative
au capitaine bien on porte le chapeau
messieurs j'ai reçu l'ordre formel de
ramener les 3 es bon en bonne état quoi
qu'il arrive
bon maintenant on va parlementer
colombani trouvez moi un bout de chiffon
blanc et bricoler quelque chose qui
ressemble à un drapeau bien mon
capitaine
que les âmes ouest à couvert et ne tire
sous aucun prétexte
qu'est-ce qu'il est fort ce mec pour
baratiner les gonzesses
[Musique]
e
et
[Musique]
nissan
micheline freund non se perdre à
homestead du bo à venise italie
ah les [ __ ]
je ne sais pas ce qui me retient
l'écraser ces petits merdeux appelle les
toubibs
je préviens les américains
est ce que c'est que ce cirque
bon allez vous comme ça si vous
permettez alors comme un dialogue sauf
si leur agresseur iphone via rail c'est
pas grave
[Musique]
si comme agnès cigref luton walo walo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le tai chi
qu'il n'y a pas une phase
on compte
je te nique
[Musique]
notre tout à côté
ce week end
baffinland cette somme jeunes gens
bizarres offre d'amp cette somme allo
ciné sun
j'ai apprise enquête ordinaire
los caidos
m
[Musique]
jamais
en somme c'est cool que martin ont dit à
auch
nagui qui signifie souvent jack canfield
bataille fut rude
mr faunique de matane socialisme
humaniste voire six ou time reagan à
l'achat sont valensi dj séparatiste
péniche troll
ce terminal est sous sa main
[Musique]
les magazines auto ait en face
guillaume dechristé bonne cela montre
furent les critiques en face aux
critiques en géomatique économe ici on
dit qu'ils n'avaient rien changé
[Musique]
rafini
infiniti
[Musique]
ces légionnaires tous sous-officiers
chevronnés ont été rassemblés afin de
participer à une opération de commando
particulièrement délicate et dangereuse
tous parachutistes tous grands
combattants des guerres modernes
ils sont en outre brevetée dans diverses
spécialités
certains d'entre eux possèdent également
des dons d'imagination et
d'improvisation qui leur ont permis de
se sortir victorieusement des situations
les plus imprévus les plus exceptionnels
c'est le passé de chacun de ces hommes
que nous avons voulu évoquer avant qu'il
ne s'embarque pour ce commando qui va
les mener vers leur destin à djeddah
vilaine
[Musique]
lorsque le haut commandement français en
indochine décida d'évacuer le nord
tonkin et les villes de la frontière
chinoise en octobre 1947 la protection
des voies de communication notamment
versé 4 entre langue sommet cao bang été
confiée à des unités de la légion
étrangère
cette évacuation conçu comme une simple
formalité tourné au désastre
les viets était partout dix fois vingt
fois plus nombreux que les quelques
milliers d'hommes qui se repliait
cependant les compagnies de la légion
qui occupaient des postes de la rc4
réussir à maintenir au prix de durs
combats la route ouverte
puis vint le retour d'évacuer la
dernière compagnie a quitté son poste se
battait sans discontinuer depuis six
jours et après ça ça descend jusqu'à
chou ce train là on n'y sera pas avant
la nuit
mon capitaine regardez les hommes
20 minutes heures pour l'entendre google
mais après on leur fait aux par hachoud
je trouverai les transports si on devait
trouver des transports résultat rien
personne désert à croire qu'il ya plus
personne que lou jusqu'à hanoï
[Applaudissements]
il y avait encore des survivants la 3
les [ __ ] dit at-il ne sont pas
attaquées à cause de notre mitrailleuse
essayant de tirer
direction toulouse et on ne peut pas se
rapprocher à cause du ravin la duchesse
est à terre raymond batterie
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'ils fabriquent et abc
qu'est ce que c'est que ces bleus
les jeunes de 1ère classe du lenn
troisième compagnie à vos ordres en
capital maintient soignant par tout de
suite donc se soigne en a le temps de
lutter ce qu'on voudrait c'est juste un
morceau de pain on n'a pas mangé depuis
deux mois malheureusement pas possible
hors jeu juste un petit morceau donc
habiter là même pas une miette
nous non plus on n'a pas mangé depuis
deux mois je suis un homme
allez on
du vrai pain avec du kynar l'épinard du
haut rhin et les puces non les futurs
mariés n'importe où y met du pain est
heureux qu'il nous fasse pas le même
bouquet lanxade ci avait personne à
givet pense qu'ils ont tout préparé pour
le recevoir
il y aura plus qu'à se servir
[Musique]
tous
et les autobus pour hanoi est inutile
d'insister le colonel est occupée il ne
peut recevoir personne peut pas ou ne
veut pas de toute manière ce que vous
demande est absolument impossible
j'ai absolument besoin de transport de
vivres et d'antibiotiques depuis huit
jours j'entends que ça m'aide pas le
seul vous êtes tous dans ce cas non
commandant les indiens de faire
d'efforts surhumains l'accompagné la
dernière c'est trop appuyé quand nous
sommes arrivés à l'ong sonne la ville
était évacué quatre jours quatre ans
jérôme au commandant nous avons tenu
quatre jours après le repli général sans
jamais cesser de nous battre et
maintenant il faut que j'attende ici
jusqu'à dieu sait quand ce sont les
ordres
alors donnez moi ce dont j'ai besoin
même si je le voulais je ne pourrais pas
toute l'intendance et évacué sur un oeil
mes hommes ont pas mangé un morceau tant
pis de moi j'étais blessé je regrette
capitaine cette discussion est inutile
j'ai des malades de dysenterie vous
crevez si on les soigne pas alors on
pourrait les sauver
n'insistez pas
troisième c'est que vous en faites
les conserves réserve défense y toucher
bien qu'elle réserve aux ordres du
colonel paul le capitaine
si ça peut vous consoler pour le pain
nous sommes logés à la même enseigne
nous non plus nous n'avons pas mangé
depuis deux mois quant au colonel qui
est d'origine beauceronne ça tourne
d'ailleurs la psychose à ce sujet il en
rêve la nuit des temps ce que j'entends
c'est bouché ou quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
les types de 3,9 les grosses de la fa 18
mois je vous toujours les petites
si tu gagnes tu deviens toute façon que
j'avais la boule quand même on va faire
un tous les deux sont là elle reproduit
un compte où mon pote je vais dire ça
moi je le dis parce que je suis là pour
le dire c'est vrai
ensuite je verrai ce que sa troupe ça
prouve qu'on a la baraka il faut en
profiter avant tout manger bon quand tu
comptes à partir de maintenant on
partage les petits sont tenus sur mon
pognon
allez-y somail le set
les petites le neuf le 8 septembre
allez-y le sexe c'est le set
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m je sais pas les 10 le sait c'est un
temps maintenant on laisse toi cet hiver
2004 il ya eu un large alors si on peut
dire mais alors qu'il y en aurait alors
allez-y
[Applaudissements]
tu cherches un moyen pour nous piquer
l'argent qu'on a gagné
l'homme muti a soif tour après la
prochaine
quang nghi très honorée pour venir le
voir racontent nature
peut-être vous restez maintenant le toit
ni clooney véritable princesse marie
paule doit être frais de la princesse
one lui va faire plus si tout ce qu'il a
ils le savent aurait pas un camion
défaut tous les camions sont partis avec
honorable soldats tout fout de moi qui
te parle d'un camion de l'armée
française je veux acheter un camion est
one 13 en or est très honoré mais quoi
ni ne peut pas donner ce qu'il n'a pas
je voulais tu nous vends une pincée ce
mode aller partout à la française alors
trouve quelqu'un qui nous vendre un
camion question de foot d'un camion
laisse moi faire alors tu te décides
c'est le moment ou jamais si tu veux pas
le teint peu de temps frais crémerie
veut rendre service lui trouver une
solution et il donne son auto assez
honorable amis et en donne combien tu
veux 2004 c'est la plus belle auto
d'issia nous y conduit la payer
très cher ou tu la cache la tontine est
celui qui montre son trésor va déjà
perdu quang nghi doit prendre des
précautions et on y va c'est qu'elle
siphonnait je veux qu'on fasse d'une
telle somme on peut sentir des
princesses boy comme s'il en pleuvait ce
qu'on trouve le moyen d'acheter ces
bagnoles pourri
[Musique]
pire
dans un sens à peu puisque la poisse
puis quand on est dedans
je n'ai pas fait
n'arrive pas à se décider je suis pas
superstitieux mais ça prague
je crois qu'être qu'on a payé
ça peut pas porter malheur
on va où comme ça
valero
exemple
vicky fait pour
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on fait
eh ben on y va comme ça on s'en va
jusqu'à la peur est valable on laisse le
le véhicule ici et on y va
[Musique]
je l'avais dit sa copine et moi je
marche pas parce qu'on est moins bien à
mieux quelle guerre bien engagés de
force ou trois mois
alors il a aussi nos vies est maintenant
nous en dit plus bas à vendre au venin
réquisitionné mois oblige et fournit aux
marchandises eux qu'est ce qui te
balance en échange je leur ai offert
donc de réquisition pour arriver à temps
pourquoi les trois cloches peut
réquisitionner nous peut-être vous pas
réquisitionner l'impôt une pauvre votre
ami vous achetez vous payez tient à lyon
pour l'attirer ont déchargé le butin
pour pas pouvoir faire salle pour nous
pas faire ça à l'ipo nous pensons que
j'ai tombé questionner du pays non pas
question
on paye c'est tombé sur la tête mais on
n'est pas des trucs et si on devait il
va nous montrer tout ce qu'ils cachent
les montviette art je comprends ce que
veulent honorable légionnaires robert
l'égard des mois
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ce cirque
où avez-vous walesa a pas volés acheté
mon capitaine ht avec notre argent vous
foutez moi vous ne voulez pas de quoi
acheter un rayon de bicyclettes je vous
le jure mon capitaine
c'est vrai mon capitaine ses nuits on a
gagné une fortune au bac one c'est vrai
ça mais oui mon cabinet je pensais pas
qu'il investirait dans les pompes
funèbres
mais vous savez mon capitaine et il a un
moulin de première et des pneus presque
neuf essais partout dégagé il est pas
beau mon capitaine elle n'a pas comme ça
jusqu'à hanoï et faute de gmc on pourra
toujours y mettre les blessés les plus
urgents
regardez il ya de la place
nom de dieu
4 que nourrir tout régiment la farine
aussi on l'a acheté mon capitaine vous
en fais cadeau
maintenant pour les jeunes c'est à vous
de jouer avec le colonel mon capitaine
qu'est ce que le colonel à voir là
dedans l'obsession mitraillade y est
vous l'avez acheté aussi est ce que
c'est
il n'en fallut sait d'où ça sort jamais
vu c'était une prime une prime comme ça
ça vaut 15 jours via mon capitaine on
méritait julienne
[Musique]
au passionne soyeux passionnant ce
rappel des opérations à effectuer pour
les conducteurs pour l'entretien de
leurs véhicules texte il est rappelé que
l'entretien est un acte les combats et
l'exécuté rigoureusement hype le général
une petite touche lorsqu'il exécute ses
fabriques ne se souvenir de tous les
défauts de marge constatée pendant la
main c'est là où je ne vous dérange pas
capitaine
vous deveniez mois non juste un petit
encas les généraux bon appétit robot me
faire le plaisir d'accepter un verre de
vin sheila un petit bruit je ne voudrais
pas abuser je vous en prie vous avez en
effet une cave digne d'un roi
la dernière fois que j'ai vu un bruit et
de ce millésime justement c'était la
langue sonne chez le colonel constants
je vois que vous avez trouver du pain et
chez un boulanger dans ma compagnie mais
sans teint est remarquable mais peut
être désiré - botter un morceau sommes
tentés par les italiens parce que c'est
un italien font du pain beaucoup plus
léger que nous et la farine
la farine vous avez bien trouver de la
farine dame
comment faire autrement ici c'est pas un
secret mon commandant je suis tout prêt
à vous révéler mes sources je vous
remercie mes hommes sont privés de pain
depuis longtemps je ferais même plus mon
commandant je vous livrerai tout mon
stock votre stock
qu'est ce qu'on ferait tous à hanoi
évidemment évidemment si vous permettez
mon commandant je fais porter ce pas
votre pc et puisque vous appréciez
m'embrouille j'en ferai aussi porté au
cola m évidemment évidemment
il est
[Musique]
où
il
[Musique]
oh
vous
[Musique]
on
bien pouvoir subban
ils ont choisi d'art
[Musique]
et puis
ça
[Musique]
soit dit
p
[Musique]